in the last video we left off in 1922 in
October where you have several hundreds
of thousands of fascists march on Rome
which causes the king to put Benito
Mussolini in power and this picture
right over here is from that is from
Mussolini coming to power from the march
on Rome and not only does he get
appointed as Prime Minister but he has
dictatorial powers for one year and
those dictatorial powers are also backed
up with the black shirts this loose band
of kind of a paramilitary group and so
he uses his powers and and the fact that
he has this his own force so to speak to
to continue to just secure more and more
power under him over the next few years
by 1923 1923 he makes the black shirts
become part of a we could actually
become a formal national militia
essentially the volunteer militia for
national security and in Italian the
acronym is the M vs n so the black
shirts the black shirts become
formalized as the MV SN he also gets
gets Parliament or gets the the
legislature to pass what's known as the
acerbo law or chair bola I'm sure
mispronouncing it a chair Bou law and
this is an interesting one because this
is a law that allowed whichever majority
party as long as that majority or I
should say majority party whatever the
largest party in the in the deputy of
Ministers whatever the largest party in
Parliament is that that party as long as
they get more than 25 percent of the
vote as long as they get more than 25
percent of the vote they will get
two-thirds of the seats of the seats in
in Parliament and and this is strange
because traditionally in a parliamentary
system if you got even let's say you
were the largest party and you got to 26
percent of the vote you still would not
have enough seats to govern properly you
would have to form a coalition with
several other parties so the
you could you could and you could you
could essentially form a government but
this is saying that whoever gets the
plurality of votes who gets the most
votes without necessarily being a
majority they will by default become a
majority and you could imagine why the
fascists wanted this to happen they felt
that they could get 25 percent of the
votes popular won maybe through popular
support but also with the help of the
help of the coercive tactics of the
Blackshirts and then that would give
them stronger stronger control in in in
the legislature now the big question is
is why would the legislature pass this
because at this point the fascists were
not the dominant party they did not have
a majority in the legislature in fact
this is why they wanted to pass the law
because they didn't have a majority and
once again it's a one of those questions
of history some would say that there was
actually people were enamored with the
fascist they were enamored with
Mussolini they were eager to have strong
leadership they didn't want this
government of coalition's they wanted
one government to be able to take action
and on the other side when the votes
were happening you actually had black
shirts in the room so one argument is
that there was also an element of pure
intimidation but needless to say the
chair of all law or share Bowl law
actually passed but there's an irony
here because it was unnecessary in 1924
when you actually have elections you
have the fascists getting 2/3 of the
vote fascists get 2/3 of the vote now
many in today and many in Italy at the
time felt that this was a fraudulent
election they felt that they were the
reason why the fascist were able to get
so many votes is that because they were
able to intimidate folks they were able
to commit fraud during the election that
they were able to kind of throw other
votes out and one of the most outspoken
individuals when it came to criticizing
the fascists and and their their tactics
of coming to power was Giacomo Matteotti
and he wrote a book about the fascists
he gave two really strong speeches in in
in
in the in the deputy of ministers where
he talks about where he ordered the
Chamber of Deputies I should say where
he he talks about the the kind of the
corruption and the and the the the
violence of the fascist a few days after
giving those speeches he gets killed by
black shirts so he gets he gets actually
quite violently murdered murdered by
black shirts and this puts this puts
Mussolini in at least initially a bit of
a bind
he he he he doesn't want to look like a
thug someone who goes out and and you
just just murders people it's not clear
that he actually Mussolini was involved
in this in any way but his followers had
committed this act and to protest
against the murder of Giacomo Matteotti
you actually have the entire Socialist
Party boycotts Parliament and this is
known as the Aventine secession or at
least a twentieth-century Aventine
secession Aventine secession is called
the Aventine secession because if you go
back to Roman times 2500 years ago you
had the plebeians secede out of protest
from from harsh rule and they go to the
Aventine hill and so it was named after
that same idea and the whole reason why
the the Socialists did this is they
hoped that by by by boycotting
Parliament that that would convince the
king to to to get rid of to get rid of
Benito Mussolini and Mussolini at the
same is also in a bind he doesn't know
quite what to do and on top of all of
this the black shirts are telling him
look if you don't take control of the
situation if you don't become a strong
ruler we're gonna do it without you we
we might even overthrow you mr.
Mussolini and so in 1925 early 1925
Mussolini makes his famous January
speech 1925 is famous January speech and
this is normally viewed as the formal
start of his of his absolute
dictatorship in this Mussolini instead
of the the instead of the Aventine
secession somehow making undermining
Mussolini's power because the king did
not dismiss Mussolini it actually
strengthened Mussolini
power he used that as a pretext he said
look all of these deputies they've
decide not to show up at Parliament
they've essentially given up their seats
and he bans he bans the Italian
Socialist Party he embraces the black
shirts he takes responsibility for them
he doesn't take responsibility directly
for Giacomo's Giacomo Matteotti murder
but he takes responsibility for the
black shirts and he gives in kind of
classic Mussolini style a somewhat
convoluted argument about how strength
how strength and violence is going to
give stability to the Italian people
obviously he's a he's a it's an amazing
orator he's very charismatic and this
essentially gives him the control he
needs and by the end of 1925 you have
the Christmas Eve law that's passed by
by Parliament that essentially puts no
checks on Mussolini's power and as you
go then into 1926 they more and more the
fascists under Mussolini take absolute
control absolute power of Italy banning
banning so 19 1926 they're banning other
parties so other other parties other
parties are banned they're starting to
force people to become members of the
fascist party if they want roles in the
government or even in any type of
institution they're trying to take
control of the press they're starting to
have a a very strong state police
architecture and if this looks familiar
based on what we studied about the Nazis
it's it's it's not a coincidence
Hitler was a he looked he admired
Mussolini in fact Mussolini's march on
Rome inspired Hitler to attempt his Beer
Hall pooched in 1922 or in 1923 a lot of
these tactics that brought Mussolini to
power you see it kind of a parallel in
what brought Hitler to power only about
seven years later